[Musique]
donc aujourd'hui on va travailler avec
fatih donc vinci à raison
c'est une première rencontre pour rené
bertrand ok c'est colette oui
on brosse les cheveux
sa relaxe son système nerveux c'est un
petit peu comme heures un massage
polaire
et c'est aussi cet apaisement que rémy
vient chercher le brossage de cheval
c'est un exercice de pierres une
présence qui nous permet de
s'approcher du cheval mais également
d'être plus présent avec notre propre
corps
est ce que ton système nerveux est calme
assez pour monter ce matin oui parfait
on retire à qui normal on passe beaucoup
de temps à parler de nos pensées et de
nos émotions et j'étais technicien
médical dans les forces armées
canadiennes pendant un petit peu plus
que tout ne va et puis j'étais en
mission en afghanistan en 2004 à kaboul
j'étais affecté dans une clinique
médicale au camp julien et puis on
recevait des des patients de n'importe
quelle nationalité qui avait d'affaires
à être là qu'ils voulaient avoir des
soins
[Musique]
j'étais bien musicalement de blessures
physiques zohra mon service et puis
quand j'ai sorti
je me savais plus qui j'étais j'étais
perdu je sers pas ce qui se passe avec
moi je me sentais mal
c'est là que la recherche d'une thérapie
a commencé leur match de caroline
leblanc lui avait été recommandée ici
les trois quarts des clients sont des
vétérans ou des premiers répondants le
cheval
voit toujours le danger donc il est dans
un état d' hiver vigilance et puis nos
clients qui qui souffre de stress post
traumatique soit toujours dans des
étoffes d'hypervigilance donc quand il
rencontre le cheval le cheval veut être
on est à cannes donc pour être honnête à
cannes le client doit se créer mais
également ses jours a expliqué un mot
pour quelqu'un qui ne l'a jamais vécu la
connexion qu'on fait avec des chevaux
c'est pas juste une connexion c'est
aussi une relation et puis au travers
d'autres ça on apprend guérir et on
apprend à connaître aussi
une connexion particulièrement
pertinente présentement alors que les
images de la gare en ukraine ravive des
traumatismes
[Musique]
entendre les alarmes à la bombe ont pas
besoin d attendre à la tv mais quand
voir les flashs et saute sur six classes
on est le petit l'entendant pape est
classé
depuis l'afghanistan j'ai pas vu encore
cette réaction est là donc on remarque
une grosse grosse différence de nos
clients ça ébranle tout le monde sa et
blanc et tout le monde sait exactement
ma première réaction était acquis quand
est ce qu'on part ça suffit la tête aux
matheux qui embarque c'est ok je veux
aller je vais y aller chez quoi faire
c'est un monde que je connais c'est
quelque chose que je sais faire
c'est pas nécessairement la bonne
réaction peut-être avoir et ça
l'équithérapie est là pour lui rappeler
pour foxes grisons le cheval m'a aidé à
rester ici est resté présent mentalement
ici
[Musique]
loin des symboles ce
que je veux
[Musique]